in terms of marketing promotion how do
you interact with your quote audience I
think that's as important as anything at
this point I think if you're a director
like me or an indie director you don't
have a big resume nobody knows who the
hell you are to get on Twitter to start
talking to people talking about your
story talking about the making of your
story is part of your job if you if you
if you want to be one of those people
that just like well I make films and
then people watch them and then I'm
going to go make more films you're just
making mistaken you're kind of a dick
because if you're not talking to your
audience at this point in history you're
losing out a on a gigantic opportunity
like didn't you want to tell stories to
people who the do you think those
people are 30 audience they're on
Twitter they'll say hi you can say hi to
them that's important and also keep in
mind Kevin Smith has this giant audience
and Edward Burns has the giant audience
that they've been building for pushing
20 years 15 years they started somewhere
so we vampire mouth has 4,000 something
followers we started with zero I talk to
people all over the world every single
day it's part of the job it's / do i do
and i also really like talking to people
all the world it's really interesting to
you know say good night good morning
when the time zones or whatever they are
to hear what so many in south africa
thinks of your show or australia
romanian UK Germany Italy I've had
audience members help translate the show
into French the whole first season is in
French and German because people
volunteer to translate it people help me
do closed captioning the thing with
having doing stuff online now if you're
if you're not on Twitter and Facebook
it's I think it's part of the job and I
that if you're talking you're I don't I
say audience member more than fans
because it changes the dynamic because
they just watch the show they're not
fans they just watch the show they like
what you do hearing what they like why
they like it hearing the responses now
that I'm writing other seasons hearing
who they'd like to see more of I'm not
saying that they tell me what to do and
I go do it but hearing like they wanted
to see more shyla the dog from the first
season in the second season so we have
more up shop that was something that was
definitely for the audience but to have
again to have people say your show
affected my life or entertain me or help
me get through a hard time that's the
only way you're going to hear that and
it's not that test group audience thing
it's it's your human being of tell
stories they're human beings who do
whatever they do and enjoy your story
why not talk why would you not talk to
those people I think it's just is a huge
missed opportunity and any and if you
are if you're in any person who's
looking to go big time or whatever
having an audience doing whatever you're
doing is always good why would that ever
be bad and yes it takes time but if
you're not investing that time then I
don't know then who watches your show
because you know I only make the story
part of the year the rest of the time I
don't know anything talking about we're
talking about the weather and coffee and
the holidays and whatever comes up but
you begin to like I now like no names of
people's kids and who has kids and that
kind of thing in it it becomes part of
your life and part of the process and
you know beyond just I have a new show
look at it you can only do that so much
you can only go look at me please
retweet please retweet look at this look
at this look at this look at this look
at this no shut up you've been saying
the same thing over and over and over
again part of its you know part of its
kind of look if you're an author and you
do a book signing it's like you're doing
a book signing all the time seven days a
week you're always talking to people
always interacting with people and
building an audience from zero to like I
said we're now at four thousand
followers whatever that translates into
interviews or fundraising and that's the
other part of it if you're not on
Twitter and you want to fundraise
something you're not going to succeed
unless you have some really famous
person that's just going to spike the
interest of that it's just hard work and
and I think most of it's done on Twitter
more so than facebook I know sometimes
you send out email newsletter up ideas
which is great I do you find that that
people also respond to that as well
since it seems like more people on
facebook and twitter now I find more
from Twitter than anything yes more than
Facebook and more than email yeah the
emails I don't do too often because it
just feels family but even looking at
the you know the report you get the
response to it is not that huge I mean
it's just to kind of let people know
when something big happens is the way I
wear something little happens or just
keeping people up to date but Twitter is
really the it's and it's very you know
it's not even official as a blog it's
almost throw away it's almost if you
type it and goes away and it disappears
into the Chum of Twitter but yeah I
think it's Twitter's the most important
part I think at least now that'll change
remember myspace and friendster hmm just
be cool
yeah yeah for an arrest
you